Male voiceover: Let's
see if we can understand
a thing or two about Futures Curves
and I've drawn two futures curves here
and really all they show is
the different settlement prices
for the different
delivery dates of futures.
So, let's say that this
orange curve is one of them.
What this says is if today,
if for delivery today,
we wanted to buy or sell an apple,
the market rate is 10 cents a pound.
This isn't the Futures contract at all.
This is actually called the Spot Price.
It's essentially the market
price for that commodity
or that security today.
We're just using the example of apples.
This tells us at time 0, you
can buy or sell an apple,
based on the current market for 10 cents.
Now, when we move to 1, the
way I've labeled this axis,
it says one month from now.
This is not saying that
the market price is going
to go up one month from now.
This is saying that today,
if you were to go into the Futures market
and say, "I want to sell,"
or, "I want to buy apples
"one month from now.
"What type of a settlement price
"can I get on my Futures contract?"
And based on this Futures Curve,
it looks like we could do about 12 cents.
I'm gonna repeat what I just said.
This is not saying that a month from now
that the market price
that the Spot Price is going to move up.
Only this time 0 is the Spot Price.
What this is saying is right now,
the market is saying,
"If you want to enter
"into a Futures contract for
delivery a month from now,
"that delivery price will be 12 cents.
"If you wanna deliver two months from now,
that delivery price
might be around 15 cents.
"If you wanna deliver
eight months from now,
"that delivery price might
be something like 20 cents."
If you wanted to show movement,
let's say all of a sudden,
people just get more bullish on apples
or there's some new
diet that tells everyone
that apples help you lose weight,
what you would probably see is
this entire curve would shift up
So, regardless of delivery date,
you would probably see
this entire curve shift up
because people would want apples
across the entire Futures Curve.
This one that we're
highlighting right now,
I've drawn two Futures Curves.
I've drawn an upwards sloping orange one
and I've also drawn a
downward sloping blue one
and I'll focus on that
one in the next video
but this upward sloping
is kind of a normal curve
and it's actually called that.
It's a Normal Curve because
this is what you actually expect
for most types of commodities.
You could imagine why.
If this wasn't upward sloping,
there would actually be no reason for you
to hold onto something.
Especially, if this was downwards sloping,
you'd be like, "Wow.
"If for future delivery dates,
"I'm getting lower and lower prices,
"why don't I just sell now?"
And that would actually
create downward pressure
on the current Spot Price
and you could of course, make
the arbitrage arguments I made
in previous videos, why you
shouldn't in a theoretical setting,
see a downward sloping Futures Curve.
What we're gonna talk a little
bit about on the next video,
is maybe why you would see a
downward sloping Futures Curve
where the delivery price
for delivery further out
than the Spot Price or
for further out months
than nearby months is actually lower
and just to give you a little terminology,
this type of curve right here
is called an Inverted Curve
and I'll talk in the next video on
why you might see one of those.